or for the government position on this
I'm joined by the crime and policing and
foreign minister Chris Phil Chris philp
good morning good morning nice to have
you with us in the studio
um we're going to come to your brief of
course later on in the interview but I
need to start with Nadine situation
surrounding him didn't the deem Sahari
mislead wish you soon act well I don't
know exactly what was said between the
two of them what I do know is that the
Prime Minister has said there are
serious questions to answer he said that
yesterday and as a result of that he's
appointed the independent advisor on
ethics to look into this properly to get
to the bottom of it so the public can
understand exactly what's going on and
uh the Prime Minister can then respond
appropriately so I think he's acted and
the premise has acted quickly he's acted
decisively he is completely committed as
he said publicly to maintaining ethics
and high standards in public life and
his actions here by appointing the
independent ethics advisor and then
initiating this investigation so quickly
demonstrates that these aren't just
words by the Prime Minister he is acting
accordingly as well so what's changed
from last week at premises questions
when he said that he took the dean's
Army his word well I think there have
been some more some more information
came out over the weekend some of that
was put into the public domain by Nadim
zahawi himself I think as a result of
that information the Prime Minister has
concluded there are questions that need
to be answered and they need to be
investigated properly and that's why
he's important got the independent uh
advisor on ethics to initiate this
investigation that's the right thing to
do so the Prime Minister didn't know
about the investigation into Nadim sahu
when he appointed him as as chairman my
understanding is that when the Prime
Minister appointed Nadim zahawi uh his
understanding was there were no
outstanding uh tax issues at that time
and I don't think my understanding is
that he wasn't aware of the discussions
that had taken place uh previously
clearly over the weekend further things
were
disclosed uh publicly which has led the
prime minister to appoint the
independent ethics advisor to
investigate and that is exactly the
right thing to do it shows that the
prime minister is acting exactly as he
said he would to maintain ethics and
standards in public life was he aware of
the penalty that had been levied against
uh Mrs zahawi and I don't believe so but
I'll say what we need to do is get these
facts fully investigated uh properly
thoroughly because you and I don't know
frankly exactly what happened and
because people's tax Affairs completely
right yeah and that's why it's it's
really appropriate that the independent
ethics advisor properly looks into this
because you know you and I would be
speculating otherwise
but when Michigan comes into office
promising accountability integrity and
professionalism with this latest scandal
with the situation around Boris Johnson
and Richard Sharp with the second of
garden Williamson with the Deputy Prime
Minister under investigation I mean
which part of those three words are
actually being lived up to by this
government well I think actually in the
way you've described that you've sort of
answered your own question because you
know Gavin Williamson is no longer a
minister in government where accusations
were made against Dominic RAV in
relation to uh bullying and in relation
to nazim zahawi about tax which you see
like as prime minister has acted quickly
and decisively to set up an independent
investigation so he's done exactly what
you would expect somebody to do who is
committed to maintaining high standards
in public life and I think your sort of
question acknowledge that right he's
done what you would want him to do okay
let's move on to some of the other uh
news um for this morning and we've seen
that review is going to be held in the
probation service after uh two men Jonah
McSweeney and um and another killer were
allowed out uh when they shouldn't have
been what's going on in the probation
service well in the case of of Zara
Alina's murder is is absolutely shocking
and the report yesterday shows there
were failings in the probation service
he was out on license he had been
released from prison having committed a
number of offenses including burglary he
then breached his license conditions by
for example failing to attend meetings
he should have been recalled back into
prison but he wasn't
um so the probation service have fully
accepted the recommendations made by the
inspector they're changing the way that
they conduct their risk assessment
they're taking into account a wider
range of circumstances I think one of
the individuals in the probation service
responsible for the decision making is
now subject to disciplinary proceedings
in addition to that we're putting more
resources into the probation service so
two and a half thousand extra probation
officers uh have been hired 155 million
pounds extra per year is being put into
it to make sure these things don't
happen again the promotion service
managed I think over 200 000 offenders
is a very large number
cases like this are thankfully extremely
rare but when they do happen they are
absolutely heartbreaking the the
um case uh is just heartbreaking and
that's why I should not have been out
there's nowhere there should be on last
street so how can the public be
confident that there aren't more people
like this out there right now as like
these cases are thankfully extremely
extremely rare but when they happen they
are truly truly heartbreaking that's why
all of the recommendations made by the
inspector are being adopted and that is
why the disciplinary action is being
taken that's why the risk assessment
processes are being widened it's why the
extra people have been hired two and a
half thousand it's why the extra money
is being put in because we do need to
make sure that the public are kept safe
and this kind of thing doesn't happen
again so extra money going in extra
offices being put forward and wider
processes let's talk about your brief
and and the announcement this this
morning about some new plans for
policing
um part of it was announced because of
the shooting of Olivia Pratt Corbell
um you want to try and crack down on
criminal gangs but just at Christmas Eve
another person was shot in Liverpool's
so is enough being done in cities like
that where there are high crime rates to
try and make sure that these kind of
crimes don't occur well the rollout of
the clear hold build uh strategy
Nationwide is designed to address these
these organized crime gangs who blight
people's lives we have seen successful
pilot work going on in parts of the
country for example in West Yorkshire uh
we saw when this program was piloted a
57 reduction in burglary a 27 reduction
in drug offenses and actually on
merseyside where it was piloted as well
we saw 420 arrests 11 firearm seizures
and 90 vehicle seizures so we're now
going to roll this out across the
country it is supported of course by all
the extra police officers we're in the
process now of hiring we're going to hit
our I believe we're going to hit I hope
we're going to lose our 20 000 Target by
by March of this year and and and if we
hit that and I think we will then we'll
have more police officers uh here in in
the country than we have ever had at any
point in the UK's history and those
extra offices of course will be partly
employed against this threat this
organized criminal gang threat we've
seen this this new uh model clear hold
build working in the pilot areas we're
now going to apply it across the country
to keep our streets safe these criminal
gangs ruthlessly Target vulnerable
people they're dealing drugs they're
very often committing violent offenses
against each other and against the
public and that's why we need to clamp
down on them and put them where they
belong which is imprisoned yeah and I
know you're short time a couple more
questions for you if we can please you
will have seen the reports over the
weekend and yesterday in the paper about
a number of children going missing from
home office around hotels in the south
of England what's the government's doing
to find those missing children yeah so I
spoke to my colleague the immigration
Minister and about this last night in
preparation for this kind of
conversation and so they are
overwhelmingly uh 16 and 17 years old
when you say child you sort of Imagine a
five-year-old but they're mostly 16 and
17. but you're not they're not
diminished I don't care they're not and
by the way some of them are age disputed
meaning they're probably over 18 and
they're not detained to be clear and
we're not not detaining them they are
they are free to to come and go and in
each case where someone has
um gone missing or absconded all of the
usual processes are followed as they
would if any other under 18 person goes
missing with the police and with the
local Authority and so that those
processes happen have happened already
as a matter of routine
um in each case and they're also on
these sites you know nurses there are
social workers present to make sure they
do get the support some of these
children have been trafficked Mr Phil
yeah so I asked the immigration Minister
this question last night and um he's not
aware of any evidence that anyone has
been um kidnapped or anything like that
if anyone does have that evidence I
would urge them to like urgently contact
the police or contact Crime Stoppers but
my colleague at the immigration minister
is isn't aware of any such evidence but
if anyone has it they should urgently uh
come forward as I say well I'm sure that
those who have it will come forward if
they do have it Mr Phil really love to
talk to you tomorrow thank you very much
for being with us